je crois que maintenant faut un peu
penser à l'avenir si on veut limiter le
confinement et en sortir le plus vite il
faut qu'on vaccine vite
c'est pour ça que l'arrêt de la
vaccination par la strade n'est qu'un
est catastrophique
outre ces jaunes rice a une vraie
connerie c'est une vraie campagne soit
pas une couille illa kané devant les
allemands vraiment c'est une grave
erreur
chaque jour de vacciner parle
astrazeneca ses quinze morts
supplémentaires en france however maxime
plus tard il y en a qui vont mourir par
fax et ils ont dit on arrête aussi
l'amérique
l'allemagne a dit en premier jamais une
heure après c'était où les fonds ayant
suivi les uns après les autres mais
pourquoi si l'allemagne est à quelques
mois des élections et la parti de merkel
va extrêmement mal et a peur de perdre
les élections il ya des jachères et de
gentils vaccin donc l'allemagne accablé
pour des raisons politiciennes et macron
s'est couché derrière l'allemagne
résultat des courses l'arrêt de la
vaccination par l'astre à zenica
ça va retarder le déconfinement ça va
retarder la fin des couvre-feux on n'est
pas prêt de réouvrir les restaurants
offrant alors juste
laurent alexandre la situation en ile de
france et ce qu'elle permet de continuer
comme ça où est-ce qu'il va y avoir un
confinement week-end comme come on you
on a on a un énorme problème à l'origine
comprennent pas forcément les gens très
âgés maintenant ils sont vaccinés
même si la france a très peu vaccinés
par rapport aux pays comparé à mai les
très âgés les gens n'aient pas disons
beaucoup été vaccinées donc on a une
baisse du nombre de morts en ce moment
en revanche on n'a pas vacciner les gens
plus jeunes et les gens plus jeunes ils
font des formes plus grave à cause du
variant britannique c'est ça et donc on
sature l'erea les gens des ehpad on les
a jamais mis en réa donc l'amélioration
la situation dans les ehpad
elle n'entraîne pas une amélioration
dans l'airé à parce que de toute façon
les vieux on n'est pas ne sont jamais
les rangs une tarière produit donc on
est dans une situation dans les semaines
qui viennent on va avoir moins deux
morts d'accord pas beaucoup plus de cas
mais d'airé a complètement agoniser
exactement pourquoi en fait et c'est
triste de le dire mais c'est parce que
les personnes avant âgée qui était en
réa mine de rien avait beaucoup qui est
décédé on les mettait pas en rire on
n'est pas dans n'allait jamais en vrai
ça en est on voilà donc aujourd'hui on a
plus de jeux jeunes auraient à casey a
longtemps
moore et des reals emboliser mais vous
pensez alors l'ile-de-france filets ce
week end ou pas on peut pas on peut pas
savoir
castex a dit avant-hier on continue la
strazeele et cas et puis quelques heures
après maquereau a dit on arrête les
aînés car c'est imprévisible on fait
m